[Music]
a stowaway gecko takes a 4 000 mile trip
in the traveler's bra oh [ __ ] four wait
4 000 miles how big are those titties
are there photos in the journey yeah
they deserve a video like can we watch
this video here i'll give you i'll give
you this i've been a pervert mike 4 000.
dude that that gecko like oh that's a
baby gecko dude unless the titty was
this big hey those are some heavies for
scale yeah scales perspective it's
either a really really really small
gecko or a huge jug some georgia tips
dude
yeah no question well describe georgia
tips are you talking about the country
or the state you've seen georgia women
they're massive they're uh they're
peaches dude thai moves slower around
them when you say peaches uh-huh
what do you mean by peaches oh you know
the kind that you uh you grab like this
and then you you grab off the tree i
understand i asked because i i was just
i was randomly in this most disgusting
thing i've ever heard
it's weird when mike says it yo
[Laughter]
what is what is in everybody's mind here
is the urban slang for peaches what does
peaches mean
ass cheeks that's a [ __ ] i thought it
was beautiful beautiful ass oh yeah
maybe you feel like today's generation
like younger people refer to it as like
ass you think it's like a peach bottom i
guess or something like that right it's
a very feminine fruit i think it was
originally based off of kundalini
specifically though right oh yeah
i think it was like very very much
that's right about a juice eating
peaches oh about the point because it's
the act of eating right
you're doing it right it's drier than
that
you gotta get one that's a little bit
ripe
because if you get it too fresh it's
kind of crispy like an apple tree so
it's not really like eating a [ __ ] a
british woman unpacking her suitcase
after a trip to barbados made a shocking
discovery a gecko that stowed away four
four thousand mile journey invasive
species ass if that was australia she
would have been in jail bro go to the
jail i heard her down at tsa there was
an air marshal you want to
hand up the gecko's ass to see if
there's anything in there
what is this
it's really good gekko do you think
though that like
one this gecko had to
stay in the suitcase it was in the
suitcase oh was it in the bra on the
lady
the whole time
because that's what i was imagining he
was gonna brought in the suitcase like
at what moment did the woman find out in
her you know like it was just chilling
there for like yeah yeah that's the only
reason i thought they were so big that's
crazy that gekko didn't freeze to death
if it's in the suitcase in the cargo
area oh but she did she check it all
right is it carry on i'm guessing it
would have to be checked because i mean
if you carry on where did it come from
tsa don't you think that do you think
tsa would see it like a but if the get
goes this small you might not see it no
tsa comes out there dude they've run
nuclear devices through tsa successfully
news channels have really and warheads
yeah bro wait where um where where where
did the stowaway gecko come from
barbados barbados
i think that's where uh what's her name
is from the uh the um i forgot her name
she's a rap i'm not she's not a rapper
she's a singer rihanna yeah yeah
she's uh actually beyond a singer her a
billionaire uh making money things from
yeah cosmetics and lingerie and stuff
like that that's very good
isn't it funny how celebrities they make
most of their money on products and
other things and not really their
entertainment career isn't that always
the case yeah that's pretty much always
look at the cloon dude the cloon sold
the tequila company for a [ __ ]
billion dollars yeah i think they use
this alba dude she got the [ __ ]
things all of the honest stuff man
that's her yeah
imagine being that hot and that rich
like [ __ ] a dude i think uh they use
their
their like
celebrity or their as pretty much just
the marketing arm for whatever they're
their own advertisement yeah like i
think reese witherspoon just broke a
billion too or something which has a
production company jordan made way more
not playing basketball on the shoes on
shoes on dude his salary was a joke
compared to what they are now right well
i mean that was always way more now
but even if like everything was relative
even with the inflation like if they
equated everything the equator says no
no exactly that's why jordan was so
smart too because he was like i'm doing
my own [ __ ] that's why he was like me
[ __ ] them kids
and then shaq was like i'm gonna i'm
gonna just make it accessible and go to
payless and everyone's like those are
cheap shoes yeah it's so funny how that
actually works right yeah i had no idea
i'm gonna make shoes for the people and
they're like nah i'd rather have jordans
but he has stock in the general the
insurance company auto insurance the
general.com oh really oh yeah i've seen
him in those games
a lot of randomly wait i think he's he
owns a lot of papa john's and yeah
louisiana fried chicken he has a
restaurant in a staple center i read he
has a passive income of a hundred
million a year just
outside of his gigs his espn sports
center stuff like just passive income
from his investments dude imagine
setting a goal being like okay now 200
next year
what do you even give a [ __ ] for it's
already passive 100 million a year why
would you ever show up on set for
another commercial no wonder this guy's
just buying people engagement rings have
you guys seen that video no i need one
shaq yeah yeah shaq met some guy at a
a jewelry store a diamond store and he
bought him his his engagement ring did
they buy a mama laptop or something
probably
if you had that kind of money you
probably just buy people buying a mom a
laptop very wholesome story buying a
dude an engagement ring to give to his
lover uh interesting story that's
supposed to be from his pocket that's
supposed to be anything but another big
ass black dude buying you an engagement
ring in the store do you think his
fiance is going to like not want it as
much
but i want some more dude imagine
telling her that you didn't buy the ring
dude that clip is viral though like that
but imagine going shaquille o'neal about
this
she doesn't know who the [ __ ] that is
because she's not a sports fan that's
always the worst
shaq is always tied to like that thing
and every single time you like bone your
wife she's thinking about shaq's dick
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that's cool that's cool that's pretty
cool she's like you want to get a
shackaroni pizza and you're like no
no check your own pizza papa john's baby
yeah dude one dollar gets donated bro
let's go that's for a good cause i'm
looking up shaq's passive income oh i
thought she was just yeah
he's doing the general i see hot dude
he's doing [ __ ] tigers bomb dude
what's that what's the car one that he's
in or like the car commercial
dude
he's in commercials now being like yeah
you know i got hemorrhoids and i'm like
i didn't know that
he's doing sears you know like this
wasn't everything he could be like if
it's hemorrhoids from me that shit's
massive
dude he'll be the commercial saying i
have headlines and then he'll be another
commercial saying you know i've never
had hemorrhoids
what product is he selling at that one i
don't know
he's crushing it
but you know i never played basketball
whatever you paid me to say bro he
should have a for sale sign on his
[ __ ] forehead what a [ __ ] g dude
this guy's killing it what was the
article about
shaq was an early investor in google and
apple and today owns 17 auntie anne's a
krispy kreme franchise and a handful of
restaurants gyms and car washes dude
this one sounds like he's laundering
money what i know he like pretzels that
much you have 17 aunties of krispy kreme
a handful of restaurants gyms and car
washes
that sounds funny dude auntie anza's
fine that sounds like a mob boss guys
right that's what i'm saying
can you imagine him manage like he's
going into krispy kreme and training his
staff and [ __ ]
or he's the hr video he's telling people
about sexual harassment
dude if he's in that car in that many
commercials he might actually be in
there yeah he's like we don't tolerate
molestation here
he does all the scenarios he acts at
when you're flipping pretzels which
business is this on
krispy kreme krispy krispy creams man
chakarona pizza when you get that rich
though like and you own these things
obviously you're not like operating um
does he have a whole freaking he's very
hands-on he's he's known to be very good
i'm like
oh i mean his commercials he's pretty
hands-on but a lot of these guys they
just own [ __ ] and then i'm and i'm like
how do you well to own [ __ ] you got to
have a team to own that [ __ ] how do you
even trust the team to own that [ __ ] for
you dude it's like well the only thing i
got for you is i watched shark tank
hella shark tank and yeah they got a
[ __ ] team he's like once you get
integrated with my team you'll see what
happens we can make [ __ ] happen and then
how do but someone's got to pick and
choose their team you know what i mean
like so shaq still got to [ __ ] watch
the team leader and the and the managers
dude and shaq wasn't even very good
teammate either because him and kobe
didn't really like each other yeah
that's true
he was supposed to pass it to kobe but
he never wanted to no kobe says passing
him that might be the ultimate diss
you're like i would join your team
bringing stream like kobe yeah but he
won some championships without them
right and one in miami with winningway
oh okay but everybody wants a
championship with dwyane wade everybody
lebron i guess was on the team too
oh yeah lebron jack is for sale he was a
laker and a celtic yeah he was a lot of
things he was like on like phoenix uh he
was in cleveland as well or those are
like die-hard rivals you know you don't
usually bounce both sides like that
unless you're rondo that's true rondo
two won a championship both
and he's coming back he's on the lakers
now yeah he's coming back right okay
let's go shaq has a 400 million dollar
net worth with about 60 million in
salary uh according to even this year's
poll
uh and he's a joint owner of silver
auntie hands over a hundred car washes
and 40 24-hour fitness centers
car washes i was watching a video where
shaq was getting like i don't know a
[ __ ] pond installed in his yard
i don't know why you're watching that it
was [ __ ] crazy i don't know it just
came up i recommend it it's a weird [ __ ]
but yeah it's the craziest [ __ ] yeah
i've ever seen i don't know what yeah
like a koi pond gigantic poncho his
house is that big town ridge over into
that tight and he's just like hey cool
guy cool job on my pawn
great video check it out shaq spawn look
for jackpot
that's tight don't watch the next jk
video go watch shax pond first and then
watch the next check and then come back
to the jk video afterwards
[Applause]
[Music]